dieses kleine mysteriöse Häuschen ist
mit Abstand das coolste an meinem neuen
Garten lass uns mal reinschauen was das
ist tada eine Kompost Toilette ich habe
die gerade zum ersten Mal ausprobiert
und bin schwer begeistert ganze so
aufgeteilt dass vorne die flüssigen und
hinten die festen Bestandteile gesammelt
werden und setzt sich da einfach ganz
normal drauf wie auf einem ganz normalen
Klo außer dass man nicht mit Wasser
spühlt sondern mit ein paar Händen
vollkompost die man einfach oben drauf
geht so kann man ganz einfach den Korb
ausleihen z.B auf den Komposter dann
kann man das ganze 2 Jahre lang
kompostieren und damit z.B die Obstbäume
den einfachen next level
Kreislaufwirtschaft